at this altitude I can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start
shaking you know I also do personal
question
no it is
I'm a cybernetic organism living tissue
over metal endoskeleton this episode is
brought to you by 99designs I've used
99designs for ages since even before
podcasting was the thing and I've used
them for all sorts of graphic design
needs they are fast and they are
convenient whether you need a logo a
website book cover or anything else I've
done competitions for instance for book
covers related to the 4-hour body
99designs makes great design accessible
to everyone and it makes the process so
much easier and I use them recently for
artwork and illustrations inside of Mike
how of Seneca set of books so this is a
collection of stoic writing and modern
interviews and so on so for the town of
Seneca I decided to use their one-to-one
project service in this case you invite
a specific designer to your project
agree on a price and then work together
until you're satisfied and the artwork
just blew my mind you have to check it
out I kid you not so you can check out
some of the artwork from Toph Seneca as
well as some artwork and logos and so on
that your fellow listeners have had made
at 99designs dot-com forward slash Tim
that's 99designs com forward slash Tim I
really suggest you check it out
and right now you guys can receive a
free $99 upgrade on your first project
this gets you I think a hundred and
thirty percent more submissions so
people who want to work with you and
give you first drafts of what you're
looking for to access your free design
please visit 99designs dot-com forward
slash Tim and click the link on the
landing page that's 99designs
dot-com forward slash Tim
this episode is brought to you by fresh
books man oh man do a lot of listeners
of this podcast and readers of mine love
fresh books to the extent that I ended
up meeting with the CEO not very long
ago why are they so popular well they
are the number one cloud accounting
software designed exclusively for
self-employed professionals that's many
of you and used by more than 10 million
people you can send invoices track your
time and get paid very very quickly
which suits the needs of a lot of
freelancers a lot of entrepreneurs and
beyond you can take pictures of receipts
you can link your credit card and debit
cards so all the things you buy
automatically appear in your fresh books
in the right category so on and so forth
makes taxes easy makes invoices easy
makes your life easier and also in fact
I recommend a PDF they didn't ask me to
read this part by the way they put
together PDF a while back called
breaking the time barrier subtitle how
to unlock your true earning potential so
you can search for breaking the time
barrier a lot of people ask me how can I
get a 4-hour workweek with a service
business and the story in that ebook its
PDF is the short answer it's really
really good so I think you should also
check that out so breaking the time
error check it out but also why not test
out fresh books claim your 30-day
unrestricted free trial at fresh
ebooks.com forward slash tim and enter
tim ferriss two hours in two S's in the
how did you hear about us section that
sounds like we're gonna get very little
tracking that's a lot of work but just
go to fresh books calm forward-slash tim
and try it out because it is a very good
product and i think you will find it
simplifies your life enjoy
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is Tim Ferriss and thank you for
joining me once again as always it is my
job to deconstruct world-class
performers from every field imaginable
to tease out the habits routines and so
on that you can use this episode is a
very special one it was such a treat and
you will realize why once we get into it
but it was recorded live at the our
itani theater in los angeles in front of
a sold-out crowd so thank you to
everyone who came this was for live
talks LA and the guest was from within
the pages of tribal mentors Terry Crews
you may have heard of Terry Crews before
Twitter Instagram at Terry Crews
Facebook real Terry Crews Terry Crews
com Terry Crews is an actor and former
NFL player Los Angeles Rams San Diego
Chargers Washington Redskins and
Philadelphia Eagles his wide-ranging
credits include the original viral Old
Spice commercials television series such
as the newsroom Arrested Development and
Everybody Hates Chris in films including
white chicks very underrated film I
think it's fantastic the Expendables
franchise bridesmaids and The Longest
Yard
he now stars on the Golden Globe
award-winning Fox sitcom Brooklyn
nine-nine
in 2014 Tyrell East his autobiography
let's stick around because this
conversation really really delivered and
with Terry you just have to give him the
ball and let him run with it and that
applies metaphorically in so many
different capacities but I really hope
you enjoyed this conversation if you
enjoyed even half as much as I did you
will love it it was that much fun and I
remember for hours afterwards I went out
to have wine and dinner with a few
friends and I just said man Terry really
really hit a home run with this evening
I mean he just killed it and I think you
get a feeling for why that's the case a
lot of these stories you have never
heard before a lot of the tips the tools
favorite books and so on the elaboration
so you have never
before Terry is a true original and here
we go without further ado please enjoy
my conversation with Terry Crews I love
Tim Ferriss oh this has been so surreal
for me first greeting you it this is the
first time we've met in person and
clapping him on the trap and feeling
like I was trying to move a steer I
realized you are in fact as big as you
look on television and first and
foremost I really just wanted to thank
you for and I mentioned this backstage
but being so deliberate and thoughtful
in your responses because I do know how
busy you are and we're gonna talk about
that schedule and you really took the
time to put intention into your answers
and people have just gone berserk I mean
it's been a very powerful impact so
thank you for that thank you thank you
and I thought we'd start somewhere that
perhaps people wouldn't associate you
with if that's even English but you guys
get my drift and that is art so I went
on to your Instagram profile not too
long ago and I saw a number of different
profiles and then I started digging and
I didn't want to tease out too much
because I want to talk about it can you
tell us a little bit about your
background with art Wow first of all I
grew up in Flint Michigan very popular
place right now I drank the water I did
a little crazy but the deal was is that
I've always been left-handed right
brained and very visual about everything
in my life and I remember
it was I have an older brother and a
younger sister and when my mom was when
my brother was off to school I was about
4 you know five years I hadn't gone to
kindergarten yet I used to just sit and
draw all day long and it was something
where I remember being inside of a
painting or a picture or a drawing and
time would stop I would be there for
almost I I remember starting a pen
drawing or whatever and it would turn in
tonight it would be eight hours have
gone by and it felt like literally 20
minutes and I got better and better and
and but but this is a deal to is that I
was always always disappointed as an
artist because it never looked the way I
wanted it to look so every drawing every
painting became this effort to make what
was in my head match what was on the
paper and I'm still doing that I mean in
regards to performances in regards to
drawing in regards to my furniture in
regards to all the things that I've ever
tried to do it's still not as good as it
is in my head and that's crazy it is
it's weird but I think my whole life has
been trying to match up with this thing
in this vision that I have in my head
and I don't think I'll ever get there
but it's fun to try so I want to dig
into a few details of this because
you're a very understated guy so you
used to paint portraits of football
players as a means of making money not
only that you had an art scholarship
before you had a football scholarship
right that's right so this isn't just me
as a professional courtesy trying to
paint a holistic picture of somebody
bigger than what you see on screen like
this guy's real artist and that's
speaking of someone that I wanted to be
a comic book penciler for about 15 years
so throughout college and everything I
was in Illustrator trying to pay some of
the bills
I was a very very bad bouncer not built
for it and and I suppose a mediocre
illustrator but I really really
appreciate that
and how did art serve you through these
17 to 20 lives that you seem to have led
man you gotta know I mean growing up in
Flint there were a number of obstacles I
mean crazy crazy obstacles because I
grew up in the I mean at the height of
the crack epidemic and also the demise
of the auto industry so there were two
things happening at once and they were
both horribly bad I mean I my it was
like the 80s probably late 70s all the
way through the 80s into the 90s was
literally the Walking Dead and it was
real I mean you had people who were
cracked out I had friends family who one
day you know whatever good people the
next day they were stealing everything
you had all the way to everyone you knew
were losing their jobs and it was a
panic and I remember there was two ways
out and one was through music and
performing another way was athletics but
our never you couldn't get paid doing
art you know what I mean it was good
everybody liked that's a wonderful
picture but it's you're a starving
artist that's the whole term you know
and I remember just saying okay I'm
gonna do this art thing but I had to do
the football thing too and these were my
ways out now I didn't believe that I was
actually going to get any kind of light
as an artist but I had one teacher one
man mr. Eichelberger I'll never forget
this and he was like I beseech arey you
are an amazing artist he was like I'm
the art teacher you're better than me
and he said you can go somewhere with
this and I was like okay but you know
nobody's gonna pay it otherwise he's
gonna pay me to do this nobody it's it's
good but I I gotta use football well he
filled out all the applications for me
and I didn't even know wow this is crazy
and he took my pictures and my paintings
and everything that I did he took and
got a photograph did all this stuff sent
him to Interlochen Arts Academy now
interlaken it's just world-famous big
deal big big deal arts camp up in
northern Michigan near Traverse City and
you study with people from all over the
world and he literally take came to me
and told me he already filled out
everything and he said Terry you have a
scholarship from Chrysler bull ride to
go to Interlochen Arts Academy and I was
like what are you talking about you know
first of all I didn't think it was
possible this is the deal there's a lot
of things you know it's weird because
you got to let people believe in you but
I didn't believe in myself and when I
got a chance to go to interlaken and
study with people from Europe and from
Brazil and from and these was mainly
music students and then they had art
students and it was just as like and
coming from Flint I mean coming from the
hood and then once I change my life once
I remember we had an and it was really
big on competition very very big on
competition it was like if you were a
violinist you had to be the first chair
and second chair and I remember all
these kids they were disappointed
because they kept moving down and it
would just feel like they were crushed
and the same thing with art they gave us
to paint we had to do two drawings and
we had the whole class doing all these
drawings and they said put your drawings
on the wall and don't put your name on
them we have the this the sky coming
from from the Cleveland Institute of Art
he's gonna judge each painting and we
want to see who's the best and I was
like oh man you know and so I did my
deal and I put all it was a wall full of
art and the the the
art guy pointed at mine and he said that
one's the best one he went all the way
across the room and he said that one
and they were both mine and I was like
[Applause]
now life is a confidence game then you
could tell me nothing I got too arrogant
I got area you have to be humble some
other way you know but that would let me
know I was like walking I can do it I
can do it
I really is good these people this is
all over the world and then I got a
scholarship to Western Michigan
University in art but it was small it
wasn't full ride but it was a small deal
so I got an art scholarship and walked
on to the football team and my mom
passed away about almost three years ago
and she always was telling me she was
like whatever you do I know you're doing
all this football stuff you're doing a
lot of other things but never forget
you're an artist babe you're an artist
I'm telling you when I see what I'm
doing right now and I get to I get to do
so many things that so many people never
got to see I get to go so many places
and do so many things that none of the
people who wanted to were able to I feel
like just there is a responsibility but
also if if I don't do it everything
they've gone through it's nothing you
know so the way I approach things is
really it's kind of for everyone else
you know I have to try it I have to go
for it and I knew even as I was doing
football and I was doing all this stuff
I remember once because football was
hard
football is a very very I get another
competitive deal you know you would get
in
get on the team and I would get cut I
was like I have to depend on this art
thing because this is what got me here
and so I will go back in the locker room
and this is how I was married I had two
kids at the time I'll go back in the
locker room and go to the players and I
would ask them if they wanted their
portraits painted and I and the weird
thing is they were like oh man come on
man you can't do and I was showing my
portfolio never like I am dude ah and I
was like look man I want to paint you
over this big you know is this I'm gonna
put you and you're gonna be a giant over
the city and I can have win you can have
wings and you can do it and let me tell
you you know football players are the
most egotistical people in the world
they're like damn yeah man I want the
wings dog huh how much put him away man
yeah and I would do these masterpieces
but you know I have to tell you this - I
did have a scam I had a scam this is the
scam in college in college I would
because what happened is I was playing
football but when you play football you
don't get money for uh for uh supplies
you only get book loans see scholarship
is a chip oh all you guys I'm telling
you the NCAA is a JEP dude the whole
deal you are not a student athlete you
are semi-pro that's all it is there's no
student in it I'm just putting it right
now and what was crazy is that I was
like hey but I want to study all right
they're like why don't you just study
business or something so you so it's
easier to get by because the whole thing
is just getting by take a class so you
can go to a football class football
practice so but I was like I'm an artist
now I okay whatever so I will go to
these labs and I would make this is what
I had a plan in the summer I would make
like probably ten paintings and then I
would make four of them really suck like
they would be really really bad and now
we bring those in and beginning and he
these laughs and I would go to the
teachers I was like man you know what's
wrong with this like help me out here
you know he was at all Terry oh my God
look okay we're gonna work on your
perspective
gonna do this and I was like yeah I know
I'll help me and then I'll go home and
then I go to practice
but like I'm up and never do anything
else cuz I had the paintings done then I
bring another one in that was a little
bit better and let me say I did this the
whole semester and then I would bring
out the masterpieces and I look how much
you helped me you took me from here to
there again the whole thing was a scam
but I had to survive I had to find a way
to stay in school cuz this is the thing
a lot of people don't know is that they
could take your scholarship it was crazy
it was one of those things where you are
there as a body and if you don't perform
they'll find a way to get rid of you so
that's a whole other subject see you you
mentioned surviving me you strike me as
a really well adapted survivor I mean
you've been through a lot you've
experienced a lot in your life and you
mentioned very briefly backstage and I
said uh-uh no I want to talk about this
in front of everybody a vow that you and
your was it your brother or your friend
made the vow that you made oh yeah
could you explain that give the the
story of that from your childhood well
first of all I what this is the oh I'd
love to demystify okay when I was a kid
no one would tell us anything anything
right and you got insane going up in
Flint Michigan's a factory town and it's
literally crabs in a bucket like if you
told people they were like I said this
before but people who say you know you
can do anything you want to do Terry
Crews you can do it you tell them what
you want to do and I like what the hell
make you think you can do that and I'll
call him on it and butt was wild it's
because again it's a factory town
everybody drove the same car you had the
same house you had every everything was
the same you went to the same stores
there was this one place called Meijer
everybody would go you would buy all the
same food it was the same clothing
everything was the same and I didn't
want any of it and I remember just
asking people how do you get from here
to there like what's the secret to this
what's the day one day you gonna find
out you just gotta tough it out and you
know I come on man you know I'm night
alright alright and so what I did me and
my best friend made a vow we made a vow
that what whenever you learn something
that I don't know
you are gonna have to tell me and if I
learned something you don't know I'll
promise to tell you and this is how I
got through my whole teenage years
because no one MHA my father it was he
was a drunk he was abusive he beaten
more my earliest memory is him hitting
my mother in the face as hard as he
could and her two getting knocked out
and I knew for a long time that I had to
do something to get out like you know
what that does to a five-year-old child
is that you realize okay first of all he
says he loves her
and he just knocked her out so what are
you gonna do to me
so I remember trying to be very very
strong as a young kid I remember I would
lift up couches that the you know make
muscles and whole thing was like I was
obsessed with becoming strong and what
was wild
is that right along with that you had to
be smart because this is this is another
thing that's crazy is that you know in
masculinity we always say hey man you
know we never negotiate with a terrorist
never but if you talk to a real
negotiator you always negotiate with a
terror now stop like first of all I had
to negotiate with my father when he got
mad it was a hey man you want another
beer what you need I'm out turn on the
TV okay what are you okay everybody be
quiet everybody because he's here and
don't say I spent all my young days
negotiating with that
then you go outside and you got the drug
dealer you got the bully you got the
gang member you're like hey man I saw a
walk on the side of the street outside
the street are we cool okay you guys go
oh you don't want me go over there all
right cool yeah all right I didn't talk
to your girl I don't talk to your sister
I didn't I didn't do so you negotiate
that I go to football and that world and
you're negotiating with coaches eyed me
tell you I had a coach who was like hey
man I like Tyrone I'm glad I got I'm
gonna call you Tyrone I said my name is
Terry coach he said I like Tyrone your
name is Tyrone
he called me freaking Tyrone do you know
how abusive that is how demeaning that
is but I had to negotiate with this guy
because he had my dream in his hand and
I was like what I'm gonna do okay this
is my way to make money is my way out of
Flint it's my way out of doing whatever
I got to do your tie wrong okay I'll be
timing right now after what I have to do
and it's so wild because you realize
this negotiation thing keeps playing and
it plays out in different ways you know
what I mean and I'm going to have to
bring it up because I want to bring up
what's happening in Hollywood right now
because you have a lot of people who are
negotiating with terrorists you're
negotiating with people who are holding
your dreams in their hands and it's kind
of wild because you know I get I've been
through all this I mean all the way from
my dad all the way up to Hollywood you
spent 20 years building this career and
I freaking have to negotiate with a
terrorist but my own dream and I'm
sitting there like wait a minute man I
don't have to put up with that I don't
have to do this I don't have to put up
with it and it's kind of wild because
you have to get to a point in every and
every job and everything when you just
had enough like there was times in the
hood
I said I had enough and I felt bad it
was a child with my dad I said I had
enough and I beat his ass there was a
time now when I've had enough with this
[ __ ]
and I said no more no more this I'm not
going for and it's why because you give
people a shot give people the shot you
give people a chance to make things
right to say hey man you know you're not
doing me right okay and yeah this is the
day I learn - yeah I'm sorry I know it's
probably some questions but I'm I'm
going on I'm tired of hearing myself
talk I know my wife says he damn near
interviews himself that's the deal
that's why she's not here tonight's the
lazy man's interview no it's just trying
to get it off my chest man I'm getting
off my chest because first of all it's
so wild because um you know once you
reach certain spots and you and you have
to negotiate with these guys long enough
to get what you need to get what you
have to have and then you can move on
and when I look at what art has done for
me and when I look at you know cuz right
now I love furniture collection of
furniture
Bernhardt gave me a collection of
furniture and I kind of you know segue
it into that and I still do art I still
paint and I still draw I plan on
literally having art shows and I mean
later in my life just really becoming
full-fledged you know with painting and
drawing and the whole thing but one
thing is that it's really bit something
that no one can take from me like it's
something I can do all on my own and I
don't care
there's no I don't have to you don't
have to like it is if I like it it's
okay and it's become one of the things
that in my life that's what art is is
it's literally subjective it's what you
want to see and again it's all about can
I get this vision that's in my hand
on this piece of paper but now it's
almost like I want to my life has turned
in art I want the vision of who I am and
who I want to be to be out in real life
I like this call myself a motivational
doer I hate talking so much like I'm a
big talker you as you can tell but the
big thing is I want to back everything
up with action I want to be an action
figure
like always always back it up with
movement don't talk about working out
you can do it all day but do it and that
was the big big distinction I've seen
especially growing up in the hood so
many people man I'm gonna do this I'm
finna I'm finna and man I said man well
why haven't you why aren't you and so
everything you see me doing I just said
I'm going I'm trying I'm going for it I
don't care and we'll see what happens
okay questions all right here all week
all right no all right so I have two two
questions related to everything you just
said and it's gonna take ten minutes for
me to get him out no the first one is
related to how you responded to all of
those challenges in an abusive father
you have an abusive coach you've all
these various challenges and there are a
lot of people who I suspect and I I know
some of them who respond to those
environmental factors by becoming bitter
and not doing so weird you develop your
optimism or that ability to be proactive
because a lot of people just opt out
they feel like the deck is stacked
against them and they they choose not to
even attempt you know I know this is
real man I learned it from my wife you
know for me yeah listen I've been a part
of this super masculine
you know the toxic masculine world for
so long and I had a come-to-jesus
meeting so to speak like literally
everything was ending right I was a
narcissist
totally still am a little bit definitely
but I'm working on just to oh this I
would say it's a it's an ongoing process
I would say over the last 17 years you
know what I mean literally from 17 from
be 17 years ago to now it was like whoa
by especially after football like once
football ended and the entertainment
thing kind of happened I started I had
to learn like you can't fight your way
out of things you have to think your way
out of things and I noticed how my wife
behaved and I noticed how actually how
women behave because women have to think
their way out of all kinds of situations
whereas guys can we can muscle our way
through and do all this stuff and and
whatever but I realized that that was
not getting me anywhere and my wife
really taught me that vulnerability is
not weakness that I had to be vulnerable
but I had to be authentic at the same
time and she would always always talk to
me and tell me that Terry you have to
you is she would always tell me the
truth
like there's nothing more valuable than
somebody who's gonna speak the truth
into your life and she would constantly
tell me this is wrong the way you're
acting right now is awful and I'm like
I'm like all these other guys cuz that's
what guys do you compare yourself to all
the other guy and you say but compared
to them I'm good right and you know
she's like I'm done oh you gonna be I'll
never forget the first time I had a big
job I remember I got a big movie and
whatever and I I remember I was walking
around at this party and I had a cigar
and I was walking around and I was man I
had two swag I had the whole thing she
was like okay you can stay over there
I'm gonna be over here talking about I'm
waiting I'm waiting and she was like no
baby
uh-uh nope nope and I was like whoa and
realize just in those little ways I was
losing her and so I had to put the scar
down and I'll come back over there she
said not ask my degree I was like wow
and then I had to be the same way with
my kids now I've I have two grown kids
um actually three now motor starters
thirty out of another ones 27 and they
were the football kids who went through
the whole mask of toxic masculinity
phase and I'll tell you I tell the kids
all the time those two I'm like look you
want cash credit whatever you get it cuz
I missed y'all up really bad I did I
missed you a bad I'm so sorry I
constantly apologize currently try to
make amends cuz I was too tough I was
too hard
I was waiting now they look at the other
ones and they look at you treat them so
good I'm like I know I'm so sorry what
can I say but again my wife has been the
example for me and I remember when I had
I you know one of the biggest fights
that I ever had in my life
was an addiction to pornography and you
know I put it in my book but the whole
thing was I had to once I realized that
I Terry Crews thought that I was more
valuable than my wife and kids simply
because I was a man and that allowed the
pornography to exist in my life because
they were objects and let me tell you
man mom I'll never forget my wife was
like I'm done I'm out I've had enough
and then at first I was like okay go by
you know I was just buying another girl
he'd be all good and all of a sudden
there was a little voice and it said
maybe it's me I was like no it couldn't
be me couldn't be I mean come on you
know she's understanding she nodded and
everything was looking out like this
everything was blaming everybody else
for what I was going through and man
that voice came back again it's like a
crack
Eggman what's that egg cracks you can't
close it up you can't seal it again it's
like man it's me it's me and man let me
tell you it was like one day thinking
that you know the the Sun revolves
around the Earth and then somebody going
no no no no no no we go around the Sun
dude and I was like oh [ __ ] right it's a
whole nother deal and I went to rehab I
went you know cuz and this is another
thing in black culture you don't get
therapy you it's beautiful
you're sorry and man I broke through all
of that and i'ma tell you man I'm I
can't
that's when it all started for me and
then the next goal was to start talking
because even now right now this right
here is therapy for me it's therapy
talking about things sharing my heart it
helps me to line up what's right in my
life and I don't have to give this man
props to remember when I told you about
looking for the answers and looking for
the question or getting questions and
trying to find answers I would go to
these books because it was all about
finding answers asking questions
questions questions I still have a thing
on my social media called the horror
questions where I just ask questions man
if we can't ask questions we're doomed
we're doomed okay I'm dead I can't stop
talking uh see when I was looking at
your history in your book in your
backstory one thing that I paid
attention to as a pattern was an
uncommon degree of self-reflection and
so I want to rewind the clock a little
bit back to high school and the the
story one of the stories that you put in
travel mentors is related to my question
related to favorite failures or a
failure that set you up for later
success
could you tell us a little bit about
that place oh man yes 1986 that was my
senior year in high school and we were I
was we I went to Flint Academy and it
was a class-c school but we were highly
ranked in the state and I was used to be
a basketball player I mean I was you
know hard to believe now but basketball
it was a big sport for me but I was the
starting center on this team and what
was wild as we were picked to go all the
way in the state we had a superstar on
our team and we had a really really good
team but we had a we played against the
school who decided not to play it was
the district championship it was right
the beginning of the playoffs and these
guys would take the ball down the court
and pass the ball to each other at the
top of the court and wouldn't play and
our we had a coach who was like well you
know what I'm gonna beat you at your own
game so we stayed in the zone so we
sitting at a whole time and I'm telling
us the most boring game of all time we
just sat there with our hands up and
they passed the ball and if anything
happened somebody went and got it and it
was core to and it was just a mess so
the score was really really low and it
they were up 47 to 45 and it was
literally under a minute and I'm
freaking out because now we're going to
it's evident we're going to lose because
I'm going man this is a dumb like
defensive strategy anyway we should have
been going after it but what happened is
a guy threw the ball there guy threw the
ball cross-court i intercepted it and
with literally five seconds left to go
and I take the ball all the way down the
court you gotta understand I'm thinking
I had visions of oh my god this is the
thing I'm the hero you know the heart is
like pounding you just you I'm already
at the party you know and I go with this
layer
and I bring it up there and it totally
gets around a rim and it rolls and let
me tell you that place goes nuts cuz it
was the upset of the year and I collapse
in a heap and I know my life is over and
you gotta understand and this is another
thing
shame among men it's like oh how could
you do that yeah other players were
yelling at me the coach at the I was in
the locker room he was like you had no
business taking that shot and I stole
the ball it wasn't like we didn't have a
shot anyway but he was like you have no
business taking that shot you should
have passed it man it's your fault and
the people and everybody in the room was
like yep and I was like they didn't let
me off one and I remember just going oh
my god and I went in the paper and the
paper next day was like Terry Crews had
a shot and he messed and let me say it
was the most dark I mean when you when
you're you know 16 years old I was who I
mean beyond cries I and one guy was
taunting me I got in a fight after the
school and the whole thing and I was
just like this is awesome it's horrible
and so it was a couple days went by and
I was in the deepest pump I'm sitting on
my bed and I shared my room with my
brother but for some reason he wasn't
there because I always remember being
there it was kind of I don't ever
remember being alone except that time
and I remember being alone and just
thinking about man what I should have
passed it
I should have passed it maybe I messed
up and you know what else could I have
done and then another little voice he
said I took the shot I took the shot and
I was like I did I did and it was kept
and I kept thinking it was like man look
when you had the chance when everything
was on the line you
took your shot man you did that you did
that and then all of a sudden I was like
that's right that's right here I took it
and I learned from then on I said man
wait a minute if I if I win or if I fail
it's going to be on my terms it's going
to be up to me ah if I have the
opportunity I have to go for it and then
I felt really good about losing again it
was red it was totally now this you can
call it reframing a lot of people have
scientific ways or psychological ways to
you know to do thing but I learned
always to kind of reframe things so that
it's to your advantage you know and you
look at these things like wait a minute
you took the shot man and I and this is
another thing because what's so crazy is
that no one ever remembers that game
it's one of the least important things
in my life but the lesson I learned is
still guiding me today the fact that go
for it take your shot take your time
when you get that thing you have that
opportunity don't mess it up because
this is another thing and I want to tell
you Tim the scariest thought ever is one
thing that blew me away is that you
really do get what you want and let me
tell you what I mean there have been
times when you can be self-destructive
and you think it's something else or you
think like I discovered it for a long
time like if I show up late or something
twice I don't want it hmm and you get
what you desire you're everything about
you you get what you want now
the way your life is truly you want it
and that's now that's hard that's hard
to say because I feel like don't wait
there's so many other option is this and
this and this and this but the truth is
is that if you wanted something
different you change it and that hit me
like it's scary because if I failed or
if I did me if I showed up wrong or
messed up on something I was like I
didn't really do what it took to get it
and that again that comes from taking
that shot way back in high school but
now I realize okay get rid of any what I
call self-sabotage and you can achieve
whatever you need you know this is this
is such a pattern that I've seen across
interviews that I've done we were
talking about Jamie Foxx backstage and
eat but it goes all the way across the
spectrum say Debbie Millman there's a
well-known graphic designer
and she realized at one point and then
made her mantra eating a busy is a
decision like you can't you're
disallowed from complaining responding
to someone when they say how are you
with a complaint that you are busy
because that's a consequence of your
decisions when did for you books enter
the picture as a force that began to
mold your guide you do you remember
because there were for instance I mean
there's a book that you mentioned when I
asked in the book about those books
you've gifted most to other pieces the
master key system master key system okay
so that's one example we but I'd love to
hear you talk about that certainly so
maybe we can start with that when did
that show up for you
Wow again I am a self-help book nut I
therap eyes all the time I have
audiobooks going nonstop and it's been
doing that I've been doing that for
almost 25 years literally I probably
read everything is why I'm a big fan of
yours but you're like there are only
these Tim Ferriss books left
been avoiding this guy for months you
know when I got this book called the
master key system and what was Wow to me
it broke down some things in ways that I
can understand because you hear certain
things
but you have to hear things in a
different way so that you can grasp it
and one of the the concepts in the book
is that in order to have you have to do
and in order to do you have to be and I
sat and I you know I would contemplate
this thing like a lot and I was like
what does this mean like what is this me
in it you know it sounded like gibberish
started a little bit like what is is
what was will be you know that kind of
stuff what will be worse but will be
again you know okay ah but but once you
really examined it is that and I'll
bring Fitness into this yes please with
Fitness you know you are fit before your
body ever gets in shape
you have to be fitness like you know
every person who lost 200 pounds can
tell you the moment way back then when
they knew they were going to be their
ideal weight that's the moment they it
was beat it was my ideal way I I'm going
to be that and and then your body just
goes right into it I heard a great quote
the other day is like follow your heart
and your body will catch up and I think
that that's the way it is with
everything is it and that master key
system book broke it down where you know
I had to say like I always had dreamed
of like man one day I'm gonna have money
one day and I said wait a minute I'm
rich I'm rich now
and this is they didn't have a pity but
when you do things and you say okay now
that I'm rich what would a rich man do
that's this is really important do you
see what would a rich man
do and I started doing things that rich
people did and once I did it I had how
do be and that was like oh my god it
worked
so I study I bought like 20 copies okay
I handed it out the air family members
and they were like come on
I had people oh thank you Merry
Christmas all right I want some money
but but it was so funny because I was
like guys you gotta understand this you
are what you are now there is only now
this is all you have it's like if
someone and I had to kind of break it
down where if you were trying to get to
LA and you didn't know you were already
here you just keep walking you keep
going you'd be all over the place until
finally you realize wait a minute I'm
here but that's kind of the way fitness
success any goal any aspiration you must
be it now that book the thing you want
to write you know that thing you want to
accomplish you have to be it now you are
an author so now what do authors do
authors write and when Arthur's right
they have a book and I'm telling you it
sounds really really really simple but
once you get it forever you will you'll
never think of anything the same way
again this this is something I want to
underscore and I'll give a close cousin
example that's really helped me so for
instance historically have been really
impatient and for a while that
aggression and impatience wasn't aid and
help in certain places but it very
quickly in excess became a huge handicap
and a big problem and so I would
surround myself with people who were
more patient more tempered calmer like a
one friend of mine named Matt Mullenweg
some you might know who that is he's a
technologist incredible guy and so I
started asking myself when I was going
into situations that I thought might
trigger me what would Matt Mullenweg do
how would not respond to this email
before I freak out and start throwing
haymakers and have to do cleanup for a
week but that's an example of like if I
were Matt right now this isn't even
though I haven't magically turned into
Matt but if I were and I acted like him
what would I do and i started making
better decisions and then lo and behold
over time started to then develop those
characteristics so i think it's a really
important point that you're making
and there's another question I've been
dying to ask you that relates to a
juxtaposition that I hope you can
explain the subtleties up a little bit
so you are and have been called the the
hardest-working man in Hollywood and
that sounds like a cliche but you have
so many different projects and I've
lived so many different lives you're
incredibly productive and going along
with that when I asked you and this was
one of my favorite parts of what you
wrote bad recommendations you hear in
your profession of area or area of
expertise and the quote was work hard to
beat the competition and this is what
you said which actually is very close to
what people like Peter Thiel and other
people say it's very very similar the
truth is that competition is the
opposite of creativity if I'm working
hard to beat the competition it actually
prevents me from thinking creatively to
make all concepts of competition
obsolete
right and I'd love you to expand on that
or give any examples of how that has
helped you in your career
in entertainment because a lot of people
for instance like out of the NFL they
don't make the transition to other
things well at all
so could you could you expand on that
Wow everything that I decided I wanted
to do in life was very competitive and I
mean sports entertainment you know it's
always been about you know it's funny
because the whole thing is that a man
it's a dog-eat-dog world you know but
dogs don't eat other dogs
they don't have you ever seen a dog eat
another dog
I've never seen it I got happy and I was
like way to me you gotta start
questioning stuff you know what I mean
because we take that like yeah man you
know we gotta fight to do this and what
happened was see I bought in I bought in
is this is how I know it doesn't work I
bought in I was hook line and sinker
about being competitive I was all to
beat everybody I would look at people I
would look at you and smile and want to
destroy you
that was my whole mo and I became a very
faked person very duplicitous very sly
very cunning very clever but there were
no real substance because it was all
about beating the other person the NFL
teaches you it was so wild is that you
had players that are on the same team
and they would play one against the
other and they would they would plant
things in your head and say you're a
little old or you're too young you don't
know what's going on and I'll never
forget one guy as an older player he was
like I said what are we doin cover two
he was like go left go left and I went
laughing every like Terry what the hell
are you doing and I was and I looked
over at him and he was like and I knew
he set me up and I said this competitive
[ __ ]
it's hard and so nana was about it's
literally it's it's scorched earth what
happens is when you compete you're just
trying to beat you this guy next to me
this guy we're at Todd we're top I'm
trying to be the best and all of a
sudden it's like you focus all your
attention on beating that guy but when
you're running you you really can't look
at the other guy and really run and
affect the race and then because they
say you know life is a race and all the
things so you say okay I'm going to just
look straight ahead but life is not a
race it's not even a race it's a
marathon and then you realize it's not
even a marathon it's a trail run
and what's crazy is that there are
people who are out here running on this
track to beat each other when all the
goals and everything you're supposed to
get is way over here on this mountain
and you just walk over and get it and
that is creativity creativity there's no
running you just do you the idea you
have and I'm gonna give you a great
example when I was approached to do a
furniture line for Bernhardt I didn't
know what I was doing I had no clue but
I did I didn't know this do not compete
don't try to beat whatever is out there
already so I created this whole thing
and I was sit in my room I have an
office and I was sitting this office and
I was thinking like man what would
happen if modern front of each if twas a
culture that you know would existed
today what would furniture look like in
Egypt and it has just started drawing
and I just started creating and I
started making and let me say it went
for days and days I can't with so much
stuff because I wasn't thinking about
anything I do way too book I was like
just what would I do
and let me tell you when I got done I
created this thing called a lily pad and
there was funny them the the chairman of
the company said Terry no one has ever
created anything like this before that's
y'all come on like I really thought he
was joking with me
and then I had all these other other
designers combination this lily pad
thing it's a chair on a table combined
no one has ever done that
you kidding me right and that I let me
tell you something I literally did Palin
just the other day
and I was we were doing interviews on
Jimmy Fallon in my lily pad shares and
he was like no one did this and it's
winning a war just doing all this stuff
and I'm sitting here flipping out
because the creativity is where it's at
I've already been trying to do a better
chair than you it would look like a
chair this would have been something
that everybody had done but maybe a
little tweak over here looks weak over
there but when you are creative it takes
you to a whole nother place I mean there
are musicians artists businessmen who
decided wait a minute cuz I mean look at
what Steve Jobs has done if you tried to
make better records you would have never
come up with mp3 and never come up with
the iPod you know it's like you have to
be so far in your own cell that and this
is the greatest thing is that there's no
one else like you there will never ever
be the world will never ever see another
you ever ever no one will ever even have
the timbre of your voice that's what's
so crazy and no one can ever do anything
like you so everything you really want
to do is original that's just the truth
and I once I started to see that and and
know and also it's a confidence game
because you have to know that your
viewpoint is just as viable because for
one I have to say you know as a
sometimes as a woman or sometimes as a
person of color or where you're from or
where you got you you feel like I don't
measure up you feel like ah you know
they're not gonna see me but I had to
bite that I had to fight all that I am
creative I'm not competing with you and
another comparison I like to say is
Fifth Avenue you go to Fifth Avenue if
Gucci with every store on Fifth Avenue
and Gucci one Gucci one Fifth Avenue no
one would go you need the success of
Gucci Prada
Bottega Veneta weave
for your thing to be successful you need
other successful restaurants because
some night they're not gonna feel like
that they want yours but if everybody
ate the same thing we would all we what
we all hate it and so this is why now
and as an actor I used to get very very
jealous you know you see a billboard
something you audition for you like man
I hate that dude but now wait now let me
tell you once I got it
I look at the Billboard and I say man
his success is my success because the
bigger he gets the more opportunities
for me and that's the truth
that's not even mumbo jumbo it's not a
joke everyone if everyone here is
successful it makes you more successful
and once I knew that and realized it it
was no going back Terry Crews category
of one right it's easier to create a new
category and to compete I love it so one
last one or two more questions and then
we'll go to audience Q&A but what I'd
love to know is as as a father you have
five kids sent right also a grandfather
with better skin than Tim Ferriss I need
to learn your secrets of moisturizing
but didn't have time to get to the gym
I'll be hitting you up later for those
questions as well but what advice would
you give to a new parent or someone
planning on having their first child
father mother or both first of all it's
not that big a deal you know and this is
with it because you overdo it
you're gonna overdo it every day it's
gotta be the right school
let me tell you something my oldest
daughter had a whole nother life I
didn't know about I'm busy I'm not
kidding you oh yeah I did it right like
wait what was that you got a whole
nother one and there you go okay you all
your preparation all you have to do is
never shame them ever never shame them
and it and literally love them till they
can't till they can't stand it anymore
and I'm telling you this because I've
made those mistakes
I remember shaming my kids when you know
the thing is Shane it's horrible because
it tells you you are bad guilt it's good
because it said you did something wrong
but Shane oh and this is what I say when
I messed up my first two you know it
feels good to shame you feel like hey
I'm doing a good thing you know what
shame on you you know you should you
know how could you do something like
that you say something like that to your
kids it's bad because then they're
internalizing and what I also realize is
that it's not every they're going to be
fine but you spend so much extraneous
energy and time trying to do things and
figure it all out for them when you have
to let their consequences teach them the
perfect example this is the perfect
example I love this example we have a TV
at home and what what happened is I
would be gone and I would come home and
I would find the kids had watched TV for
like eight hours I'm like what are y'all
doing this is crazy I gotta let you
watch the TV and I come back you still
on TV this is not so when I turn it off
they were like oh
and I and it was wild and I was like man
I turn up and so what I did I got this
thing called a Bob and Bob is a little
box you attached to your TV and it plugs
in through the TV and every kid gets a
cold and you could set it for half hour
hour two hours whatever so I was like
okay you kids are only gonna watch TV
point out so I set it for an hour and
the whole thing and they come in with
their code and I would leave they're
watching TV and I come back they're
sitting there like and I'm like what
what happened Bob but see this is the
deal how about did you watch your TV
they go yeah and that's okay you did
good okay but they weren't mad at me you
understand I mean it wasn't it was there
consequences they did what they were
supposed to do they played it all out
and now they are feeling the effects of
their consequences they are feeling
their own discipline as opposed to me
always behind them pick up your stuff no
no why aren't you doing this why aren't
you doing that
and all of a sudden kids just look like
he's gonna do it he's gonna and now I'm
just a great thing about being a
grandparent you know yeah they're gonna
be fine dude send them home Baba but
just don't be that into it and let them
feel their own consequences it's a
beautiful thing man and it's hard it's I
promise you your first child is gonna be
hard so one of the things I really
appreciate about you and that led me to
want to reach out to you is how
forthcoming you've been about your
difficulties and some of the challenges
you've faced because I think a lot of
folks we see on magazine covers and so
on unfortunately give people the
impression that they're flawless they
had all figured out and then people feel
uniquely flawed in some way that they're
damaged because they're not that person
that's unachievable could you share with
us a story of any dark period in your
life and how you found your way out of
it
things that helped you to MMM navigate
your way out of it a lot of dark dark
time you know what I'm gonna share this
story which was which changed my life I
was first I was literally just got my
first job in entertainment I was on the
TV show called battle dome where they
they literally put me in a cage and I
fought my way out yeah it was so
entertaining you know it was pre MMA you
know I mean so people hadn't seen blood
on TV yet you know we were like the
first it was really nutso people were
bleeding or the hospital it was called
real warriors real pain and I played
this character called t-money
and that's my actually my wife's pet
name for me now she's like hey t-money
and we call this the Christmas from hell
because here I wanted to come home I
went home to Flint Michigan with my
family now you got in Sam my kids at the
time I had three high five total now but
I had three kids at the time and the
girls were and they were all girls they
were very small they had never grown up
with violence in the house okay they've
never seen it and so I told my father
before I came I said hey man don't act
up do not act up and he said I ain't
gonna do nothing you know and I'm okay
so I'm bringing a family I know it's
Christmas time so just relax man and we
gonna be there to be fine so we get
there we haven't we're having a good
time my wife and I are going out we
actually are driving to Detroit to hang
with friends and I get this a call and
it was panicked my aunt called me he
said Terry your daddy hit your mother in
front of the kids
he got mad he knocked her tooth sideways
now we literally I stopped the car
we turn it around I tell my wife okay
we're gonna go over my ass that you take
the kids go to ass house the whole thing
I'm done I'm dealing with this first of
all I went in this house he was having
nerve to still be there and I said dude
what are you doing he was like shut up
leave me alone I could do it the hell I
want
oh let me tell you something I beat this
guy for about an hour he was pleading
for his life I was like I'm not a child
anymore I am a grown-ass man and how
does it feel you are about to get what
my mother has felt and I laid it on him
he was hurt bleeding laid out I'm
surprised I didn't kill him and I felt
not one ounce better I remember falling
on the ground crying in tears it didn't
make me feel one bit better not what
like now I was just down there with him
this is this is the revenge I've dreamed
about my whole life and now nothing now
I'm just like you and I remember just
feeling empty cold just I don't know it
was the dark it's probably the darkest
place I've ever been because this is the
man who's the reason I'm here and I put
him in his place so to speak and I'll
never forget it was just the most hollow
hollow feeling I've ever had we got out
of there it took me years to overcome
that like we got out of there I got the
kids out we never came back I mean we
live with like forget the holidays we're
not doing this but after years of
therapy and it's just this was literally
about six six or seven years ago and
this is what I'm talking about happened
99 okay so I go back and I said and I go
back to my father and I've been been
listening to things and trying to do
this thing correctly and I remember I
just said I have to find one thing that
I can tell him that that he did good and
I said and we called him big Terry
because his name is Terry too so it's a
big Terry man I want to thank you
because if it wasn't it wasn't for you I
wouldn't be here and if I had to choose
my parents I choose you because the
truth is he's the reason I'm here if it
was another person I'd be another person
so I said if I had to choose my parents
I choose you
let me tell you something he he just
broke down he said Terry I'm sorry I'm
sorry I've beaten your mom I'm sorry for
everything I did listen man I have never
what those words broke him down he cried
in my arms for about the same time as I
was beating him years earlier and I was
like this is not hollow this feels good
this is healing and I said man I have to
use my strength for good because
everybody can knock somebody out but to
give a hug with muscles there's a whole
nother matter and I said that is how
that's that's the vulnerability that's
the authenticity that's where real
healing takes place because Shane wants
punishment it just wants to get back
boom boom and it's temporary
but Gil develops discipline when you
admit I was wrong
could say shame is when secrets and you
don't say anything but guilt says I did
it I'm sorry and then you develop the
discipline to change man that get it was
one of the darkest periods in my life
but totally reversed and I decided
that's gonna be my life this is who I am
now some people got the ass but I'm
trying to tell you in between it now I'm
trying to tell you is it one thing that
some people try to take that and get out
of it what but what I wasn't saying is
that the big thing was is that I knew I
could that would never be the only way I
would ever use that is to protect it's
to protect not to get back not for
revenge
there's a time but I'm telling you man
that was a period that I learned forever
not again my father I wish I could say
he changed he kind of went back to his
old ways
but I'm healed and I did the things I
needed to do and I said thank you
[Applause]
and look forward to this interview for a
long time thank you for that as well and
I'm gonna ask one more question then
we'll go to audience Q&A and it's
related to a question that I posed to
you in the book because whether it's
looking at some of your early decisions
as a child or the the toughness that you
showed in athletics or doing what other
people might consider risk risky by
trying to create your own category in
many different worlds or having that
second conversation with your dad I
think there's a quote that really
exemplifies you and it's actually a
quote that you gave me in the book and
it was in answering the question if you
could have a giant billboard anywhere
with anything on it what would it say
and why and it begins with God will not
could you give us that quote please and
explain its importance obey God will not
have his work made manifest by cowards
Ralph Waldo Emerson it's my favorite
quote I literally have it on my dressing
room put on the wall in giant letters
because you know fear begets more fear
but courage just begets more courage and
like you don't even get to be born
unless your mother has the courage to
have you any great thing any just from
literally creating a business to to
making art it takes this courage it
takes this willingness to be looked at
to be judged to be you have to face down
your fears and you have to step outside
and go and it helped me to just lay out
what I was afraid of because that's the
big thing you know you have to ask
yourself what are you scared of and then
you have to attack you have to literally
have to lay out
I remember now you you told about your
swimming experience I was always you
know you know you when you grow up in
the ghetto they are they they kick you
into the pool and these are not good
experiences okay and so you know we
didn't grow up on a nice pool in the
beach and the whole thing it was like
the hood and it's like oh man it's not
good so my first experience was
horrified I almost drowned and so that
one of my fears was swimming and I
remember when I had a house with a pool
and I remember going in the backyard and
just diving into the deep end over and
over again to get rid of the fear and
it's weird because you get near the edge
and you go oh man
here I am I have to beat it so I was
just jump in and just keep jumping in
and keep jumping in until you're not
afraid anymore because remember it's a
confidence game and that quote just when
you think about anything that's made and
anything that's created anything that
you see that you admire takes so much
courage because people are going to
judge it and people are going inside at
sucks you know especially in the age of
the Internet hoo-wee you know
everybody's coming in and chipping in
with whatever they have to say and you
have to be willing and you have to be
vulnerable in order this is why
vulnerability is actually strength
because the vulnerability is part of
courage you have to be willing to let
people judge your stuff willing to let
people hear your song willing to let
people hear you sing and it's so wild
because I never forget I was at a story
for that is that the first time I ever
got a movie it was a big movie it was
with Arnold Schwarzenegger it was called
the sixth day and I'll never forget I'm
like I'm thought I thought it was gonna
be like a quick roll it turned out to be
a big job that worked six months in
Vancouver and I'm like oh my god and the
first day I was on set I was right I had
to say this my Adam Gibson come with us
you know please come with us and I
remember
said action and I walked up on the
Arnall and I was a Adam Gibson we need
you to come with us and he turned and
looked at me and I was like and wait and
I mean and I mean lightning fast all
these everything went through my head
like you don't deserve to be here you're
just a dumb football player you are a
farce these people are gonna figure you
out you are fake you're a phony
you fooled everybody it's a wrap they're
gonna find out and I'm gonna kick you
out of here that's lightning fast and
then something was wrong with the camera
they were like oh you know what we got a
problem with the lights and can we gotta
give us five minutes and this was all
split second and I remember cuz I froze
I had no our problems and I remembered I
just went to the side and I was like
Terry
okay you survived and I fell do you want
and I atom out god I left the NFL I was
sweeping floors I was doing security and
then I went this acting and I said do
you want to go back to sweeping floors
do you want to go back to security so I
make go in there and say these lines man
and I litter is custody myself out it
was like yo get some guts do and I walk
back in there and they were like
actually on the Adam Gibson you know way
and Arnall was like this guy like his
Energy's got a lot of [ __ ]
it's amazing I like him is really let me
tell you after that I learned go in
Russian Russian there's never been a
time I've been active for [ __ ] almost
20 years and it's never been a time
those boat those and it's done and
that's why I want to demystify this
thing I've never been a time that I
don't have those bubbles right before
actually never ever it's always there
don't let anybody trick you and act like
oh man I'm good if you do every day if
they that good they don't care I'm
trying to tell you if you if you care
you're gonna always be nervous you're
gonna always have to face it but when
you walk in it turn into a mirage and it
just starts to disappear I remember when
a set of white chicks
it disappeared I remember I was rolling
and I'm Keenen Ivory Wayans I was like
you got any notes Keita he was like man
do what you do man and I remember just
blowing and everything you know people
who know and that a lot of people here
who understand it if you ever been in a
flow it's amazing like there's a time
when all the light that the writing just
comes that the lines just come the job
is smooth you're like man I could do
this all day that's by practicing facing
that fear fear fear just going in going
in going in till you hit that song man
it's a high like you will never ever
ever experience I encourage everyone and
I'm not here I'm here to demystify it
you will be nervous always but go anyway
it's beautiful Terry Crews all right I
talk too much I could listen for hours
my wife has had enough of this she be
and I hope my god can we get out so we
have we have a number of audience
questions I think we'll just jump right
into it and then if they're directed at
one or both of us we'll just play some
improv jazz here so this one is from
anonymous my favorite person especially
on the internet but this is a good
question and I'll post this one do you
imagine your 95 year old self time
traveled and came to you right now what
advice would he give you my 95 year old
son self so my knife self so okay yeah
yeah I was like okay that's a deep wood
tree back to the future quite a movie
right now okay um what would he tell me
yeah
yeah if you're if you're very old self
came back to this moment and we're to
give you advice what would it be hmm
I would like to think he would tell me
you you're doing the right thing
because actually and then beyond it's
more so now than ever you start to
wonder you know I'm doing it I'm going
through this whole you know I'm part of
this whole sexual harassment thing
that's going on in Hollywood and you
have to be start to doubt like should I
have come forward
should I said anything I don't know
because I don't even know to be and I'll
be straight honest I don't know if I'm
going to have a career that's just real
the people I'm talking about are very
very powerful they run everything I'm
just me and they're very angry
so retaliation is one thing that happens
and this is but this is the truth this
has been happening to women for
centuries centuries they've been trying
to do that thing just trying to go to
work they rebuff some guy and he's gonna
fire him and get his revenge and they
end up getting their dreams messed up
but I want my 95 year old self to say
you did the right thing everything
worked out and I'd say it's kind of dark
because you just don't know but also at
the same time I like it here I like the
adventure I like not having everything
planned out I told you even coming out
here I don't want to know the questions
I just want to go off the head because
this is where the excitement is you know
I mean I've never wanted to be safe and
comfortable I mean it's it's it's
exciting here
and another thing is is that with every
person that comes out after and says
you're you adding to the story helped me
courage begets courage and that's the
way it's supposed to be I'm with
[Applause]
what was that thank you thank you
[Applause]
so this is this is a question about
changes and this one's directed at me
but I'm gonna also ask you since you've
turned 40 years old recently what
lifestyle changes have you made if any
mostly it depends and ensure that's not
true I decided to turn my head upside
down put my hair in my face if I can't
grow it on top life's honestly the the
lifestyle changes are not changing
what's worked does that make sense I've
heard at every what people would
consider milestones whether it's twenty
five thirty four it's all downhill from
here it's all downhill from and I'm like
yeah you're saying like you stopped
doing everything you're supposed to be
doing I was like I'm just gonna keep
doing the very simple approach that I
have that's regimented it's certainly I
mean your warmup would kill me it sent
me to the ER probably but I have my
simple approach that seems to work and
it's really not using excuses to stop
doing those things because they seem to
keep me strong so not many lifestyle
changes the only major change that has
become very important to me at least in
the last six to twelve months in
particular is paying tremendous
attention to trying to fix a lifelong
habit of berating and brutally attacking
myself with my inner voice I've been
extremely unkind to myself most of my
life and there have enough time to
unpack that right now but yeah that's a
bad things happened to me really early
and that made me very angry and I used
that anger as a tool but as and said you
know the anger is sort of the acid in
the vessel it damages the vessel more
than anything that's poured on and I
really realized that in the last six to
twelve months that if you want this is
my conclusion at least like if you want
to love people fully if you want to
share your gifts with the world you
cannot do it if you just tolerate
yourself you cannot do it if you don't
love yourself
sounds like an indulgence it did to me
for a long time it's not it's not a
nice-to-have it's a must to have so
that's psychologically emotionally the
the biggest change that I'm trying to
make now you are
even though you look 23 are about to
turn the big five oh I'll be 50 so what
lifestyle changes have you made or what
are the most important habits to keep
you looking 23 well I've been doing
intermittent fasting for about five and
a half years and man that was the most
valuable lifestyle change for me you
know I found that now again I I see
people who are much younger than me you
know I wouldn't I really wouldn't
recommend it for 20 year olds just cuz
you know you can eat like four pizzas
and be fine you know but as you get
older and you know I grew up in the bro
science era where it's like seven meals
a day a lot of that and so it blew me
away I read this book called a man 2.0
and engineering the Alpha and it was
like this is crazy like you know it was
unthinkable that my guys you only eat
eight hours in a and a day and a 16-hour
fasten I do it every day now some people
have seen the benefits one day a week
the whole thing but for me I do it every
day so what does your schedule look like
it's I eat from 2:00 to 10:00 and what's
wild is that you know I have amino acid
drink tea water when I'm fasting and
then at my first meal it's that too and
sometimes it goes beyond it cuz
sometimes I'm not even a hungry and so
like 3:30 and I gave it today I had just
one meal and I don't feel bad at all I
mean I learned to get by with less food
I feel more energetic and I and to be
honest with you I think more so than
physically it's a spiritual thing I
think for me everything that is within
your grasp is not meant to be in your
hand
learning and teaching yourself to say no
and you tell your body what to do you
say no because what happens is if your
body will always lead you well you know
if you listen to it you're gonna have a
problem
and I I you know there were years where
I listened to it and it got me in all
kind of trouble and so now I'm like no
you're gonna do what I tell you to do
and you're gonna eat when I tell you to
eat and it really really is an amazing
thing there are lots of scientific ways
that it approved at it as well but for
me it's a spiritually what is your I
can't help myself been asked a couple
follow-up questions here what is you
have a default or go to first meal look
that a go to meal that is your first
meal of the day
oh yeah omelette and salad what is in
the omelette it's it's usually bacon a
little cheese we've got a lot of bacon
supporters oh yeah bacon is a gift from
God man God will not have his work made
manifest without bacon that's Terry
Crews okay there are the healthy fats
and the whole thing but a little cheese
bacon in an omelet along with a great
salad or some vegetables right there and
that's my go-to meal I can eat that
anything like that's the first thing I
usually have any time when I break my
fast that's it and it's light enough it
doesn't feel heavy I've tried like
grabbing a big Brady sandwich before and
it's just oh my god you're gonna you go
to sleep immediately it's so nuts but
that's the kind of meal that I love all
right almost for me tomorrow see if I
make it to three o'clock alright this
question is this very hyper specific
I'll take a stab at this seems to be
addressed to me this is from Tia Carrere
amazing all right so this is yeah thank
you for coming this is a really specific
question what are your thoughts on
cryptocurrency and could you maybe
interview mic Novogratz on your podcast
so mike Novogratz
well-known investor recently made the
statement that he has I think 5 or 10%
of his net worth in cryptocurrency and
blockchain fascinating guy I actually
know Mike I've gotten into some scuffles
not in a bad way with Mike because we
both have wrestling backgrounds he's a
much better wrestling he supported the
USA Wrestling program and we met
actually in lighting the several places
but in Iowa when I first met Dan Gable
who was a hero of mine legendary coach I
ended up in this book up so yes I'd like
to have Mike on and he's actually the
brother which I didn't put together
until Jacqueline was already gonna be in
the book with Jacqueline Novogratz is
also just an incredible incredible woman
so they have an amazing family so yes
I'd like to have him on the podcast and
I'm sure he'll bust my balls half the
time it is a very tough dude which I
invites that's perfect my thoughts are
crippled my thoughts on cryptocurrency
are there be dragons on the map I would
say be very very careful I'm not a
cryptocurrency expert I do know a lot of
experts and I even though I own a little
bit of cryptocurrency I'm very very
cautious to not take the DIY approach
because there are a lot of bear traps
and I will say that I think most icos
are going to end up giving people
nothing I think many of them will be
regulated out of existence and the
technologies is very sophisticated and
they're also very sophisticated
technologists who can trick most people
into giving up their money for something
that will end up poof just being
vaporware so I think that cryptocurrency
and blockchain have the potential to be
as important as what we consider the
Internet and I'm really borrowing from
some of my smarter friends in saying
that having spent 17 years before moving
to Tejas before moving there 17 years in
Silicon Valley I really know some very
very smart people and actually like
vitalik the creator of aetherium and
zuko the creator of Z cash and many of
those folks
because I'm so interested in it are all
in tribe and mentors I wanted to kind of
get them all in one place to see what
patterns came out of it did that with
poker players - I tell you shouldn't
take all of my investing advice but but
I would say much like picking stocks
you're up against professionals so you
wouldn't bet on yourself if you were
playing golf against Tiger Woods I would
hope not unless like someone in the
audience it could happen here is
actually that caliber similarly if
you're playing on Wall Street or playing
in the world of crypto you're dealing
with people who do this all day every
day and know all of the nuances so just
be very cautious if you have an
informational advantage and you're
playing with chips you can afford to
lose
then I think it's it's something that's
that's very interesting to explore just
as a way of learning about the
technology and the implications it might
have so it's endlessly fascinating and
endlessly terrifying
I suppose in short it's not a call for
an incredible laugh all right see yours
here's a question from John and I'd love
to hear your thoughts on this when do
you decide to mentor someone what
attributes do they manifest to become
mentor and then there's a bonus old
Buddhist proverb when the student is
ready the teacher appears how do you
decide who - not necessary a mentor it
implies sort of like full-time unpaid
extra job but to help someone to invest
in really helping someone you've had as
eyes as I understand some some people
have really helped you along the way
whether the art teacher
you mentioned Sylvester Stallone I
believe that is another so when it's
when you have the opportunity how do you
choose you have limited time limited
energy how do you choose who to invest
in well to me it's um it's a little bit
about a little bit it's a lot about
desire you know I've come it's why
because I've come across I've had people
who were in my circle who said they
wanted things and then when once they
realize what it took you know
and so now I would anyone that I'll be
willing to mentor or whatever would have
to I would send them on like little
tests I mean really it's like you really
have to really want what you're going
for and my wife because I made the
mistake before of this making it too
accessible you know and and it's again
it's kind of like you know people have
to it's you you have to desire you you
get what you want but there's a lot of
people who's just trying it out and you
hear people say they want it and there's
so many so many things like me as a kid
when I wanted something I always would
would go out of my way to you know show
that person who I wanted as a mentor
that I'm willing that I show up early
I'm there but I've had guys who man
you're like okay be here at this time
and you know it's funny I'm waiting on
them and immediately it's like it's over
I get and everybody gets a shot for me
everybody gets a shot because you don't
know until you get that time but you
know you show up late a couple times I
have one assistant who like just forgot
a whole bunch of stuff that I
desperately need it and you're like this
is just not important enough for you you
know and then you have to let them go
and what's a while is that you know
every time I let somebody go though we
have this come we have a conversation
because I want to make sure that it
wasn't me so I'll say ok you tell me
your fire so don't even have to worry
right right I was like yours no hope of
you getting your job back so tell me
what I did wrong and tell me what
offended you and I get really honest
answers that way and and it has helped
me become a better a better employer or
a better mentor but also you know
there's been other times when neighbor
was just like dude I messed up I messed
up and
I realized that I had an opportunity and
I pissed it away and I was like wow well
you you won't do that again
on your next job I usually don't go back
that's another thing that I always have
to do I even wrote that in a book about
letting people go and it's part of the
process you know
so you mentioned letting people go not
just in terms of employees but people in
your circle yeah the people you grew up
with yeah how do you break up with a
friend or how do you how do you have
that conversation can you give us an
example I mean do you have to name names
of course but this is something a lot of
people and myself included struggle with
like you realize this this is it this is
this is someone who was a great Apple
and they've turned into bad apple and
they're starting to poison this the
entire group effectively or have some
negative impact but you've known them
for so long yeah how do you navigate
that could you give us an example well
you know first of all we have a lot of
talks as we go to say that hey man we
have to do this we have to be held to
this standard like I have an example
there was a one person I told him you
know he's a single man but I also said
hey man you have to understand that I'm
a married man and if I hear any drama
about women in this your circle that's
going to be a no-go for me because you
know you have to treat everyone with
respect I don't want any of that coming
to me and I said you got understand
because if it is and if it happens once
I'm gone and he was like oh man I would
never do yeah I understand I know man
yeah I got your thing man I understand
what you're talking about
until it happened and I went do what did
I remember what I told you you know what
I have to do right
and he just said yeah I get you right
and I said okay sir
amen love you I love you like a brother
I wish it could have worked out and it's
a very close friend and I mean super
close and I says man but I gotta go on
without you and you know it's weird
because Hollywood as one of those things
that's built on this kind of camaraderie
entourage whatever I don't have that
because for one I found that the
entourage has you they know all your
things and they start telling you what
you're gonna do and it's like uh you
know and I said never me
I'd rather go alone and I'd rather walk
alone so but it's it's hard because
sometimes you do feel lonely you do feel
like but the higher up you go the more
is at stake man I mean it's good you can
everybody can be down there and you can
be hanging and everybody's good but let
me tell you soon as you get something
and it's as soon as it becomes bigger
than you and more important than you you
gotta let some of these people have to
go they have to and it's not personal
and I tell them I love you but we just
can't anymore and I'll be brutally
honest but not mean is that you don't
have to be mean some people feel like
you got a but I've always I love you man
but it just we just can't we can't hang
so what do you do if you've made that
decision and then they reach out to you
or you feel the impulse to reach out to
them because you've just known them
they've been part of your pattern for so
long well how do you ever sell yours how
do you respond in either of those cases
the you know I've I've blocked people I
mean you put a foam block on I've
changed my number I do that a lot I mean
they have talking family members family
members who's like man I'll have people
who call me up and angry because they
felt that I should you know I should be
paying for this and I should be doing
that and all of a sudden I just
disappeared and it was amazing when the
phone ring
the answer that's the trick you know
it's a trick did you think oh no I was
like blog and all of a sudden it was
quiet oh wow this is beautiful
okay that's kind of scary I block so
many people like but but they get it
after a while but but now every every
relationship in my life must be
voluntary
it must be voluntary if if I had my wife
tied up in the basement is it love
no you know I make all my relationships
in my life love based meaning you want
to be here if you're here you want to be
with me if you're my even my managers
people in my circle you can are free to
go at any time even my wife and my wife
was like I'm done I love it I almond L
don't leave please and she was there I
gotta go I'd be like damn I would be
hurt but I couldn't hold her because it
has to be voluntary but that works the
same way for me too if I want to go you
gotta let me go if I say I gotta go you
gotta say okay I'll respect that I
understand and this way all your
relationships are really good ones
because everybody wants to be there and
it's a beautiful thing
thank you take a few more I know we're
running over time everybody cool I'm
having fun you guys have fun
I didn't ask Terry Terry you okay no I'm
having fun I felt those traps I don't
want those inflicted on me
all right a few more questions what
advice do you have for an introvert who
wants to be an entrepreneur but does not
like socializing this is from Rosa I'd
love to hear your take on this I'll give
a quick my quick piece because I
definitely view you as an entrepreneur
first and foremost I'm not by I
shouldn't say first and foremost but see
entrepreneur let me just not rant but
I'm gonna get my words out for a second
it entrepreneur if you look at the root
of the word is is from and I'll just use
the Spanish because it's easier and but
in there to undertake right it's someone
who is effectively creating something
from nothing so an artist is doing that
there many different forms of being an
entrepreneur and you do not have to be
extroverted and yeah all you have to do
to realize that is to watch for example
early interviews with any people you
view as tech luminaries now it's the
most Awkward footage you will ever see
in your life and then they get media
trained and they'll sit there like and
you're like oh my god it's the clown
from it that's really creepy
that is what you think normal humans do
okay so you don't have to pretend to be
something you're not
you can be shy you can be introverted I
do think that it it is very valuable
perhaps as an experiment to do what's a
Warren Buffett did who was very
introverted at one point and he trained
himself in public speaking by going to
Toastmasters and so on I do think that's
useful as an experiment to not just
assume that you are in some way cursed
by being introverted you may in fact
have the capacity to do other things but
to be a successful entrepreneur on
almost every level you do not have to be
an expert at network and you do not be
have to be an expert at socializing you
just don't need it so you can definitely
do you and still succeed I don't know if
you know I mean I was really amazing
advice I think that um people have to
confuse boldness
with being an extrovert yes but I've
seen very amazingly bold introverts who
I just they just know who they are and
what they want and that doesn't that you
don't have to be loud you don't have to
be brash and it's really really a cool
thing when you see us funny when you see
a little old lady who runs this gigantic
business and she's got her thing
together she's didn't beat she's just
walking there with a quiet voice and
everybody shakes because they did oh
she's some she means business and that's
that kind of boldness that it doesn't
take a loud-ass she just knows who she
is and she knows what she wants and
that's a man that's all you need I'm
with you yeah I mean if you're good at
what you do and I mean so good and I'm
totally stealing this from other people
but so being if you are so good that
people cannot ignore you like you will
not be denied that's right
you can I mean look at some of the
people out there in the world they are
weird as [ __ ] all hell and yet if
they're good it's just like
what are we gonna do I know less person
out there so be the embrace your weird
self that's my friend Kris Zocco it's
saying all right so we're gonna do last
question from the audience and then I
have one closing question for you what
are your recommendations for coping I'm
abbreviating a little hear
recommendations for coping with
self-induced anxiety so I'll just give a
few thoughts real quickly because you
know some families you have baseball
families everyone's good at baseball all
their families everyone's really good at
basketball I feel like my family if not
everybody but like 80 90 percent
professional warriors this is
this is just their speciality
so I've I've developed a whole
repertoire of different ways to induce
anxiety and myself has proven not to be
very fruitful I will say in retrospect
but a few quick recommendations if
number one is there's a book and there's
a lot of books like this that have
terrible titles and actual good content
some that sound like infomercials maybe
it's come to mind but the one I'm
thinking of is how to stop worrying and
start living by Dale Carnegie and this
book is surprisingly sophisticated it
offers an entire toolkit for exactly
this it's it's very very powerful and
then I would say lasts just for my piece
is some form of the exercise that I call
fear setting which is completely
borrowed from 2000 plus year old
philosophy called stoicism and I'm
cribbing from Seneca and others who have
done this practice but if you guys
simply search the word fear setting that
is something I do probably every month
certainly every quarter for defusing the
anxiety and those my two pieces of
advice actually the new one which is in
the last year is I something I added to
what I normally do in the morning which
is journaling and that is if I'm feeling
extremely anxious or overwhelmed and
they're very closely related I will ask
myself what might this look like if it
were easy and this could be project
could be a decision it could be a
contract it could be a relationship it
could be breaking up asking someone out
doesn't matter and simply asking that
question then writing longhand does a
lot to take the nebulous monsters in my
head and to trap them on paper and to
see that they're actually just shadows
I'm terrified by nothing in effect so
those are a few thoughts but anxiety do
you have recommendations for people for
coping with anxiety um I believe I'm not
I can't be certain
this but there's a quote in that Dale
Carnegie book about living life in day
tight compartments man you do know
yourself up foot I'll tell you let me
tell you man that right there I say I
take those nuggets and I go that is a
fine book it's a wall
it's again we have the same issues it's
all one again those bubbles that anxiety
the whole thing and when you're just
living there's like just get today done
today don't worry about tomorrow don't
worry about yesterday just today and man
it feels like all the shackles all the
just you start to feel peaceful and it's
a beautiful thing but that's a such a
great book man it really so right yeah
that's one of the books I'm gonna have
in my living room on the bookshelf cover
out which isn't a great way to put books
on a bookshelf but because I want to see
the covers of certain books so that I'm
reminded of them and if I'm feeling like
I'm going into a tailspin or beginning
to get lost in some way I know that I
can pull that off and go through the
highlights it's a fantastic fantastic
book alright last question which I think
I said 75 questions ago Terry Terry what
would you like to say or ask as just
parting words it could be an ask of
everybody who's here who might be
listening on the podcast it could be a
suggestion anything at all that you want
to ask if people or simply say I guess
the big ask that I have for everyone is
that and this is one quote that really
really gave me a big big perspective is
that people are not objects to
used they are people to be loved and my
big ask is that you see everyone as
people to be loved because you know and
one thing I see now how in America
especially with the partisan everybody's
democratic or Republican or this or that
a black or why and then it but we're
people to be loved and it sounds very
cliche or whatever but when you get down
to the heart of it when you look at
another person see them as a child we're
all like kids and that all of a sudden
you could see it much more differently
because you could instantly love a child
you can feel the love or a child a child
doesn't know a child is biggering it all
out and the truth is we don't know and
we're all figuring it out just please
please please before you call somebody
an [ __ ] on the internet you know well
before you you push send on that tweet
that's gonna tell everybody off just
know know that this is a person that
needs to be loved and there are a lot of
people who are getting off on what you
don't know and they want to treat you
like an object didn't treat you like
property and treat you like people who
things are bought and sold whatever and
whatever but man then I just ask that if
you ever get into that stop and think of
them as people to be loved
ladies and gentlemen Terry Crews
let's go oh yeah good thank you all for
coming thank you very much hey guys this
is Tim again just a few more things
before you take off number one this is
five bullet Friday do you want to get a
short email from me would you enjoy
getting a short email from me every
Friday and that provides a little morsel
of fun for the weekend and five bullet
Friday's a very short email where I
share the coolest things I've found or
that I've been pondering over the week
that could include favorite new albums
that I've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up in
the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com
that's 4-hour workweek com all spelled
out and just drop in with your email and
you'll get the very next one and if you
sign up I hope you enjoyed this episode
is brought to you by fresh books man oh
man do a lot of listeners of this
podcast and readers of mine love fresh
books to the extent that I ended up
meeting with the CEO not very long ago
why are they so popular well they are
the number one cloud accounting software
designed exclusively for self-employed
professionals that's many of you and
used by more than 10 million people you
can send invoices track your time and
get paid very very quickly which suits
the needs of a lot of freelancers a lot
of pipe under Lowe's and beyond you can
take pictures of receipts you can link
your credit card to debit cards so all
the things you buy automatically appear
in your fresh books in the right
category so on and so forth makes taxes
easy makes invoices easy makes your life
easier
and also in fact I recommend a PDF they
didn't ask me to read this part by the
way they put another PDF a while back
called breaking the time barrier
subtitle how to unlock your true earning
potential so you can search for breaking
the time barrier a lot of people ask me
how can I get a 4-hour workweek with the
service business and the story in that
ebook its PDF is the short answer it's
really really good so I think you should
also check that out so breaking time
error check it out but also why not test
out fresh books claim your 30-day
unrestricted free trial at fresh
ebooks.com forward slash tim and enter
tim ferriss two hours in two S's in the
how did you hear about us section that
sounds like we're gonna get very little
tracking that's a lot of work but just
go to fresh books calm forward slash tim
and try it out because it is a very good
product and i think you will find it
supervise your life enjoy this episode
is brought to you by 99designs
I've used 99designs for ages since even
before podcasting was a thing and I've
used them for all sorts of graphic
design needs they are fast and they are
convenience whether you need a logo a
website book cover or anything else I've
done competitions for instance for book
covers related to the 4-hour body
99designs makes great design accessible
to everyone and it makes the process so
much easier and I use them recently for
artwork and illustrations inside of my
cow of Seneca set of books so this is a
collection of stoic writing and modern
interviews and so on so for the Thao
Seneca I decided to use their one-to-one
project surface in this case you invite
a specific designer to your project
agree on a price and then work together
until you're satisfied and the artwork
just blew my mind you have to check it
out I kid you not so you can check out
some of the artwork from top Seneca as
well as some art
in logos and so on that your fellow
listeners have had made at 99designs
dot-com a forward slash temp that's
99designs comm forward slash Tim I
really suggest you check it out and
right now you guys can receive a free
$99 upgrade on their first project this
gets you I think one hundred and thirty
percent more submissions so people who
want to work with you and give you first
drafts of what you're looking for to
access your free design please visit
99designs dot-com forward slash Tim with
the link on the landing page that's
99designs comm polish slash Tim
you
you
you
you